[Musique]
dis-moi iznogoud effectué à faire les
courses
est ce que tu peux me prendre du
boulgour du quinoa du tofu du pain sans
gluten et des haltes s'il te plaît ah
c'est bon t'as bien noté ouais je me
tâte ou directement brice plus rapide
bon voilà j'y vais je vais au
supermarché à la biocoop
je dois aussi aller au yoga ce soir yoga
j'ai pu beaucoup de place en fait si tu
veux aller au bout des 6 et massot le
concept était super simple tu donnes des
vêtements les plus hype que tu mets plus
et ça profite aux miséreux dans le
concept je vois par exemple tu avais ce
jeu-là proche de l'aveyron et elle
s'occupe du reste
mais attends avec mes peintures énorme
en fait c'est toi qui a un grand coeur
tu viens de donner ta veste je suis
comme j'adore cette veste je peux
l'essayer
oui à tout mais c'est parfaitement matin
et en plus elle ferait un parfait saout
feat drake va comme un gant
j'adore cet assaut 1 alors moi je
connaissais déjà asos mais paaso bah tu
connais les deux terminé les deux amis
tchèques voilà je fais de la
luminothérapie ce excellence et quads en
fait une longue spéciale qui agit
directement sur le cerveau grâce à un
spectre lumineux très très proche de la
lumière du soleil un ouais alors il ya
un truc qui est pas mal aussi dans le
même jour s'appelle ouvrir les volets je
sais pas si tu tu connais puisque je
vous jeu dans le concept c'est excellent
en fait en ce moment je suis à fond dans
l'humanitaire avec des potes en affaires
courantes founding à vous avec l'enfant
d'un wayne la couarde forme d ouais et
du coup on a réussi à réunir assez
d'argent pour faire construire un puits
dans un lieu défavorisés à temps mais on
est carrément dans une cité la noël
en fait en ce moment j'essaye de me
créer un petit espace feng shui dans ma
chambre
ah ouais c'est quoi en fait j'essaye
d'harmoniser l'énergie environnementale
de ma chambre pour favoriser mon
bien-être
on vend quelques modifs de meubles ah
ouais mais du coup tu dors comment là
bas c'est très simple regarde j'ai mis
mon ya l'envers je me mets comme as tu
vois et je dérape
[ __ ] mais c'est excellent ce du stent
les pings quoi mais mais je suis un peu
crevé à temps et un chien j'avais ap
n'ont carrément ap c'est mon nouvel
animal de compagnie ah ouais carrément
fucked up
j'adore le concept ouais il s'appelle
wagner et puis tu vois lui et moi on est
franchement connectés attend mec tout
cas que c'est un petit peu touchy de
garder en laisse tu devrais libéré man
louette a raison c'est cruel en fait
ouais
pendant qu les as well d'oise où il a
atteint le vert quoi à le malaise
ah non mais attends mais la nature n
aime pas la nature en fait ça leur fait
un action c'est une [ __ ]
l'une est d'avoir en fait on a tous les
deux des minettes [ __ ] et arras ah ça
c'est peut-être moi ça qui a bien pu là
alors moi j'ai rien fait c'est lui moi
j'ai juste mis 5 euros dans le
crowdfunding c'est tout frère on a déjà
de l'eau c'est quoi ton délire ouais
mais là il ya là carrément plus pouvoir
il ya un petit malaise
moi j'ai aquabike tu dois y aller moi
j'ai carrément yoga en fait alors là en
fait je t'emmène une soirée ultra
éphémère
tu connais non je connais up en fait
c'est une soirée qui dure juste un
certain laps de temps
ok et voix ok c'est parti voilà c'est
terminé merci à tous excellents tout cas
me away je te présente abricots ma
nouvelle petite copine salut excellent
alors vous êtes cops est en couple libre
en polyamoureux howard libertinage en
fait nous on a une vision du sexe et de
l'amour complètement nouvelle en fait
c'est à dire que en un concept de
koulouba on s'embrasse pas bon se
touchent pas d'ailleurs en fait on
s'aime pas en fait je veux pas de lui
wayne on avait pas de moi vois donc
c'est pas ta meuf quoi nous annonce pas
d'un boeuf en fait pourquoi ils nous ont
mis là je comprends à moi je sais pas
nager à temps mais seule une dame tout
envie de faire un art
mais à la coiffe temps mais on
business good mais qu'est ce que tu fais
là je fais du son d'un excellent on peut
faire un feat
tu veux fit et ouais ok alors avec moi
one two three x
[Musique]
ah tiens